Most moviegoers will just sit back and enjoy
a film’s story as presented, but there are
others who may think something else is afoot.
After a few repeat viewings, the more curious
audience members will start to piece some
evidence together and create their own interpretation
of what’s going on.
And honestly, they may be on to something.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 movie theories
that will blow your mind.
Star Wars
Even the most devout Star Wars fan has to
mock the ability of the Imperial stormtroopers,
as they frequently miss their targets despite
being trained soldiers.
But what if it was all on purpose?
A theory suggests Darth Vader instructed his
troops to miss the main heroes because he
had bigger ideas for them.
Consider that the Empire learns the location
of the Rebel base after the Millennium Falcon
escapes the Death Star, which wouldn’t have
happened if they were all killed.
When the stormtroopers are shown to be efficient
killers in the opening scene, it starts to
make sense.
Pulp Fiction
Ever since its debut in 1994, fans have been
trying to figure out what’s in the briefcase
Jules and Vincent pick up.
The only hint is a glowing aura of gold, but
some think they know what’s in it.
Could it be Marsellus Wallace’s soul?
When Wallace first appears, he has a band-aid
on the back of his head.
It’s a religious belief that when the Devil
takes your soul, he does so through the back
of your head.
Not only that, the combination to unlock the
briefcase is 666, which is the number of pure
evil.
It’s a sound theory and gives a classic
film a spiritual layer.
The Rock
Did Michael Bay make a secret James Bond film
when he directed The Rock?
Some believe Sean Connery’s John Mason is
an aging Bond.
In The Rock, Mason has been in prison for
33 years, lining up with the peak of Connery’s
Bond tenure.
Also, it’s noted that “Mason” has no
identity and doesn’t exist – correlating
with the classic “James Bond is a code name”
theory.
The script plays into it further, revealing
Mason was trained by British Intelligence
and is a lethal killer.
Mason even parodies Connery’s one-liner
from Diamonds Are Forever.
It may be wishful thinking, but it’s too
good to not be true, right?
The Avengers
Earth’s Mightiest Heroes seemed to take
care of an Asgardian god a little too easily,
but what if Loki was in on the whole thing?
One theory says that he lost to the team on
purpose so he would be taken back to Asgard
by Thor when it was all over.
He then could launch a diabolical plan to
claim the throne of Asgard, and he’s coincidentally
sitting there at the end of Thor: The Dark
World.
As the god of mischief, Loki is one of the
most cunning and intelligent Marvel characters.
This paints him in a better light and makes
him an even more devious villain.
Aladdin
Everyone loves the Genie, but some are confused
by his ability to imitate modern celebrities
– since the film takes place in the past.
But what if it’s set in a post-apocalyptic
future?
A slip of the Genie’s tongue may have given
it all away.
At one point, he remarks that Aladdin’s
outfit is “too third century”.
But when he first appears, he notes that he’s
been trapped in his lamp for 10,000 years.
That would make the year 10,300 at the earliest,
perhaps even later to explain Genie’s knowledge
of 20th century pop culture.
How else could he know about third century
fashion?
Reservoir Dogs
By now, most movie fans know Tarantino’s
films are connected in various ways, but some
ties could be larger than others.
Some speculate that the events of Reservoir
Dogs and Pulp Fiction’s Jules and Vincent
story take place on the same day.
This would explain why Jules and Vincent are
able to fire guns in an apartment building
and drive a blood-soaked car in broad daylight
without any police interference.
LA’s finest are working hard at stopping
the jewel thieves of Reservoir Dogs, so they
don’t have time to handle another disturbance.
It is crazy Jules and Vincent get away cleanly,
so maybe there’s something to this.
The Dark Knight Trilogy
Christopher Nolan’s Batman series emphasizes
the close relationship between Bruce Wayne
and his butler Alfred, but what if they were
something more?
One theory proposes that Alfred is actually
Bruce’s biological father.
The evidence is somewhat slim, but a closer
examination of their interactions holds some
clues.
Alfred seems to be very emotionally attached
to Bruce to be just an ordinary butler.
He seems to be looking after someone who’s
his own flesh and blood, but that could be
an effect of being Bruce’s surrogate parent.
It’d throw the origin for a loop if true,
but Nolan’s been known to bend minds before.
We’ll leave this one up to you.
Toy Story 3
Sid, the villain from the first movie, comes
back for the third instalment, making a cameo
as a garbage man.
That seems like an odd profession for someone
who was so adept at building things, but there’s
a solid reason behind the choice.
One hypothesis is that Sid became a garbage
man so he could save toys that have been thrown
out by other owners.
He is presumably the only human in the universe
to see toys come to life and knows they’re
more than just pieces of plastic.
In an effort to make up for his past crimes,
he becomes a guardian of the toys and protects
them from the dump.
Titanic
Audiences fell for the love between Jack and
Rose, but what if Jack never existed?
Some suggest Jack was just a figment of Rose’s
imagination as she fought a bout with depression.
Jack represents her fantasy of the ideal man
while she deals with an abusive fiancé and
helps her work up the courage to stand up
to him.
The film notes that there are no records of
Jack, and Rose says he exists only in her
memories.
That seems odd, even for a member of the lower
class.
Could Titanic just be a romantic version of
Fight Club?
We’d like to think so.
Ghostbusters
Even though Egon says that the Ghostbusters
shouldn’t cross the streams, they do just
that to stop the bad guys and save the day.
But things may not have been as happy as they
seemed.
Theorists have suggested the group died after
crossing the streams, and the celebration
that follows is an elaborate fantasy.
As for the sequel, the theory suggests the
Ghostbusters are in purgatory.
The second film repeats the events of the
first, though slightly skewed, and nobody
appears to recall what happened before – even
though a giant marshmallow attacked New York.
There’s something strange in this neighborhood.
Those are our picks for movie theories that
will blow your mind.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones are your favorite?
Sound off in the comments section below and
subscribe to our channel for more fun videos
like this one!